ce sont ces poissons c'est une très
mauvaise idée apple ça c'est un rendu
publié par le site japonais macotakara
un site spécialisé dans les rumeurs les
infos apple règle générale voilà ce que
nous dit le site macotakara sur l'iphone
10 aces et 17 max de cette année apple
pourrait nous proposer un triple capteur
photo sur le principe c'est plutôt bien
plutôt une bonne nouvelle c'est bien
qu'apple évolué je dirais semaine
compliquée pas forcément au niveau mais
en tout cas cherche à rattraper pas son
retard face est un peu délicat qu'apple
cherche en tout cas à continuer dans la
course parce qu'ils ont été vraiment
bousculés cette année notamment par
huawei et l'idée d'abord un trip capteur
photo ça peut avoir du sens sauf que ça
la grosse prod tube errance careï vous
avez là alors là c'est un bon paquet
évidemment vous en douterez le
smartphone n'est pas là sinon jouera une
exclusivité mondiale ça serait génial
donc est-ce que pas vous montrer le
relief normalement il devrait être un
peu en relief comme ce que vous avez sur
le relais des iphone 10 aces et 10 s max
sauf que salah comme ça là franchement
ça me paraît pas joli du tout alors il
ya d'autres propositions qui ont été
montrés par d'autres sites qui seront
bien voir un module photo qui est
intégré sur le haut du smartphone deux
caméras un flash au milieu bon je vois
pas trop comment ils vont intégrer le
troisième but photo ou alors carrément
intégrer un troisième module photo un
peu de la même manière comme ce qu'on a
eu l'année dernière et l'année d'avant
sur l'iphone dit ça il faut le dissès
iphone du sexe max 3 modules photo à la
verticale ça me semble en tout cas être
la meilleure proposition parce que oui
apple commence à faire parler lui
forcément y avoir des iphone qui vont
arriver en septembre 2019 et ont
commencé à essayer de deviner ce que
peut nous proposer appel parce que si on
est un peu le contexte 2010
8 s'est donné un peu compliqué quand
même pour apple les iphone sont très
bien iphone 10 16 17 max 10r de très bon
smartphone mais qui reste quand même
cher par rapport à la concurrence et
certaines fois en dessous ce que propose
la concurrence en termes de performances
en termes de qualité photo ils ont été
vraiment détrôné en partie en tout cas
par huawei l'année dernière mais qui a
vraiment fait une énorme progression et
apple qui quand même empathie d'une
manière ou d'une autre c'est un peu
délicat
malgré tout un peu le reste une marque
de confiance une excellente marque mais
qui reste relativement cher on va
essayer de comprendre un peu ce que peut
nous proposer apple voir un peu ce qui
devrait se dessiner justement pour ce
deuxième semestre 2010 9 et j'espère en
tout cas apple
si vous regardez cette vidéo s'il vous
plaît apple ne fait pas ça comme ça
c'est vraiment pas très beau pas
particulièrement bien intégré et j'ai
peur que pont coup ça vous dessert plus
qu'autre chose et si on comprend un peu
ce qu'on pourrait avoir donc trois
modules photo ça peut paraître
intéressant on va que tout le monde
ils y arrivent déjà fin 2018 en 2019 il
ya de plus en plus de constructeurs qui
équipent leurs smartphones avec trois
modules photo ce qu'on voit et ce qui
marche plutôt bien en ce moment c'est un
premier module photo je dirais un peu
grand-angle standard pour avoir des
photos un peu classique un deuxième
module photo pour avoir un très grand
angle pouvoir capter ce que vous ne
pouvez pas capté autrement et puis le
troisième c'est un téléobjectif qui vous
permettra d'aller faire des zooms x 2 x
5 voire même carrément x 7,8 fois ce
qu'on pourrait avoir sur le b 30 pro on
verra d'ici quelques jours le 26 mars
prochain donc je vous invite à vous
abonner parce que je serai à la confesse
je vous dirai tout justement sur ce
nouveau patron pro de huawei apple ne
dérogerai pas à la règle et proposerait
lui également un combo photos gagnantes
qui lui permettrait d'aller plus loin en
terme de qualité photo pascal se reprend
un peu la base apple a vraiment gagné
beaucoup de clients et de consommateurs
grâce à la qualité de ses photos sauf
que dernièrement vous avez pu vous en
apercevoir
c'est un petit peu plus difficile pour
eux il ya beaucoup d'acteurs sur le
marché il ya beaucoup de bonnes mains
avec d'excellents smartphones qui font
de très bonnes photos donc apple n'est
plus là
seule marque à proposer de bons
photophone un peu difficile pour eux ce
qu'on devrait avoir cette année c'est
donc un iphone 10s je ne connais pas le
nom mais en tout cas un successeur de
l'iphone 10 16 qui devrait avoir un
écran de 5,8 pouces oled
on resterait sensiblement sur le même
format une encoche plus petites plus
réduite toujours un oeil side 10 et un
triplé module photo à l'arrière alors un
triplement du photo l'arrière oui et non
il ya une rumeur qui dit que en fonction
de la performance de votre smartphone
par exemple si vous prenez un modèle 64
giga ou 128 giga vous n'auriez que deux
modules à l'arrière tandis que si vous
allez sur une config plus haute
vous auriez bien les trois modules photo
ça serait pas une nouveauté qu'apple
différencie sur un même produit des
options si on peut appeler ça comme ça
en fonction vous preniez le package le
plus complet ou alors le moins complet
ça ça reste à bord on aurait donc un
iphone aussi 10 s max qui lui par contre
devrait d'abord les trois modules photos
de base ils ont toujours en écran de 6 5
pouces oled bien évidemment à auch plus
réduit forcément parce que ça c'est
aussi un pancréas est un petit peu
compliqué pour apple si apple reste
exactement sur la même copie au niveau
de son encoches ça va être dur parce
qu'on va t en coche disparaissent de
plus en plus soit avec des petites
bulles soit avec des en cochant goutte
d'eau soit carrément indécent ligue 1
donc si apple garde cinq grosses
encoches à mon avis en 2019 ça ne
devrait pas le faire
je pense qu'apple va continuer son
travail sur la réalité augmentée qui me
coûte l'a déjà dit par le passé
il croit fortement en la réalité
augmentée pas trop en la réalité
virtuelle qui enferme davantage sa
pelouse déjà montré dans nombreux usages
en nombreuses qui note
il utilise la réalité augmentée et ils y
croient donc apple devrait aller encore
plus loin dans ce sens notamment en 2019
bien évidemment un smartphone optimisé
pour les conditions de faible luminosité
et qui on l'espère sera toujours
meilleur pour vos photos alors on aurait
un autre modèle c'est l'iphone 10r
qu'ils continueraient à exister 6,1
pouces lcd et qui lui par contre aurait
droit à un double module photo ça
pourrait être assez intéressant donc une
montée en gamme du point de vue de tous
ces smartphones pour l'instant on ne
connaît pas le nom est ce qu'ils se
rappelleront les iphone 11
est ce qu ils s'appelleront iphone tout
court il y aussi une rumeur qui fait
état d'un smartphone qui pourraient
aller sous l'eau
alors je suis pas sûr de luz à ce que
tout le monde ait révélé dans cette
piscine
c'est déjà tenté que vous aviez une
piscine ou dans la mer avec vos
smartphones mais a priori c'est un
smartphone qui potentiellement selon les
rumeurs pourrait aller sous l'eau sans
le verra très prochainement les
successeurs l'iphone 10 aces et 10 s max
devrait conserver le 3d touch et apple
devrait aller plus loin au niveau du 3
octobre proposant plus d'options pour
l'instant ça n'existerait toujours pas
sur le successeur de l'iphone 10r qui
est lui par contre rien toucher à pic à
la place d'un évidemment des smartphones
toujours plus puissants plus performant
avec la puce à 13 une rumeur
intéressante elixer iphone de 2019 pour
être compatible avec l'apple punchy
alors ça c'est intéressant parce que si
vous remontez en 2007 à la première qui
note première présentation des iphone
par steve jobs c'était justement le fait
de dire à cette époque là il y avait
beaucoup de smartphones qui utilisaient
des styles et et steve jobs avait dit qu
yves un style et personne ne veut un
style et des arcs
sauf que on voit que les styles et
reviennent quand même en avant faute
devant de la scène et 6 12 ans après à
peu laurence et iphone compatible avec
un stylet ça montre quand même qu'à un
certain renversement alors le contexte
n'est pas le même entre 2017 et 2019
mais si ça se fait ça est quand même
très intéressant dans l'histoire de la
marque
alors cet iphone pour avoir de la
recharge l'inversé notamment pour venir
recharger ses airs pop
ils auraient une plus grosse batterie
une meilleure autonomie il passerait en
4 gigas de ram au lieu du 3 giga de ram
classique et apple pourrait
potentiellement laissé tomber son port
lightning pour aller vers de l'usb tilt
c'est pour rendre plus compatibles ça me
paraît aussi avoir un sens surtout qu'on
voit que les les macbook pro les
derniers macbook pro sont 100% usd ses
fans aux connectiques donc là aussi pour
le coup ça pourrait aussi avoir un sens
il serait également équipé du wifi 600
farc voilà on n'en sait pas plus
aujourd'hui c'est des smartphones qui
devrait être présenté début septembre
est dispo septembre/octobre bien
évidemment le tarif on ne connaît pas
mais on imagine connaissant apple
forcément ils vont être très cher dites
moi vous ce que vous en pensez qu est ce
que vous pensez que ça est ce que ça
vous paraître bien est-ce que vous
pensez que si apple va là dessus c'est
une bonne chose moi je suis pas fan non
je suis vraiment vraiment pas fan mais
ce que je regarde avec un oeil nouveau
mais cette espèce de gros blocs ça me
semble être vraiment
arnaud yeux par rapport au reste du
design s'il ya vraiment un gros
déséquilibre et ça fait une espèce de
gros pavés lors de ce côté là
franchement apple
si vous faites ça je suis pas vraiment
convaincu dites moi vous ce que vous en
pensez en commentaire comment vous
trouvez
est ce que ça vous intéresse et qu'est
ce que vous pensez de ces différentes
rumeurs au sujet de l'iphone 2019 bien
pas bien intéressant pas intéressant
vous marquez tout ça on reste connectés
je vous embrasse invite à regarder ma
playlist qui vous parle des différents
smartphones du moment qui peut être par
là où par la jeune rendez vous demain ou
bisous à deux matchs